what is php
php used to stand for personal home page
now it is considered to stand for hyper
text preprocessor
php allows you to create dynamic web
pages php is a server-side programming
language and it is a scripted
programming language what this means is
when you are sitting at your computer
and you open a web browser and you go to
a web server if that web server calls a
php script this script in its entirety
is run on the server itself and then the
results from that script are sent to
your web browser to your client it is a
scripted programming language what this
means is that the programs are not
compiled they are created in a simple
ascii text editor an interpreter is
installed on the web server and then
when the script is called that text file
is read by the interpreter on the server
and that is what's turned into the
programming language to do whatever the
program says
finally this is a great cross platform
programming language and what this means
is it can work on windows servers can
work on linux servers and it can even
work on mac os x servers so you can use
php on iis and on apache web servers to
create dynamic websites
with standard html web pages basically
what you see is what you get everything
has to be hand coded if there are any
changes with php you are allowed to
create interactive websites so
from html you'll be able to send emails
you'll be able to read and write to
files and you'll be able to read and
write to mysql and other types of
databases
essentially what happens is when you go
to a web page with your web browser that
will be created in html now if you go to
a web page with an html form that html
form will point to a php script so it
asks if it asks for your name if it asks
for your email address if it asks for
any information that information will be
sent to a php script and then that php
script will be able to send that
information out either as an email it'll
be able to save it into a file or it
will be able to save it into a database
php can also read from files and
databases and dynamically write html
code to create dynamic html web pages
as an example this is a simple php
script i have written this php script on
my windows computer simply in notepad
and called it nugget.php
now with php scripts you have to tell
the interpreter that this is a php
script so you open the php script with a
bracket question mark php this opens a
script
here what we are doing is we are
creating a variable called greetings and
we are setting the value of the variable
to the string hello world
we then want to print out to display on
the web browser
our greeting so we will display the
value of our greeting and we want that
within the h1 tag so these are the
standard old html h1 tags and then what
we're going to do is we're going to
close the php script so this opens a php
script this closes the php script we set
we create and set a variable to hello
world and then we are going to print out
the value of that variable
so i've uploaded this to my own web
server this is simply a godaddy account
web server to
www.elitecomputerguy.com forward slash
test forward slash nugget.php and now we
see hello world has shown up so php has
written hello world on this webpage the
important thing i want you to see though
is if we go to the source code
we can see that all that has been
written is the h1 hello world we see
none of the other code
that the php script ran so we do not see
if hello world came from a database we
do not see if it came from a file so all
how
this code was written this html code was
written is protected uh so that you
don't have to worry about hackers trying
to figure out what databases you're
using or what files you're using and so
on
so php is used to create dynamic web
pages this allows you to use html to be
able to write to files write to
databases write to email it allows you
to pull information from files or
databases and write that into html code
the reason that i suggest most people
use php is there's a relatively easy
language to learn if you're a new
programmer and the php interpreter is on
almost every single web server that's
ever been deployed unlike ruby on rails
or some of the other web programming
languages php is on everything so if you
go out to godaddy.com or 101.com or any
of the other thousands of different
hosting providers they will all have php
so if you write php code you know that
php code will be able to run on those
web servers if you need to find out any
more information about php please go to
php.net and there is just a plethora of
information
they can tell you everything in the
world about php so i hope this has been
informative for you and i'd like to
thank you for viewing
hi this is alex from php academy and
this is a quick guide to installing
apache mysql and php on your pc so you
can start using it as a web server and
start developing in php
basically it's going to be in very short
chunks of explaining different aspects
of this i'm not going to go through the
install process because that's
relatively straightforward
if you go ahead and google or head over
to the url that you can see in my
browser now
for xampp
this is a package that i've used for
about five years now it's very basic
does the job
it's not very you know intensive on on
your system
and essentially it contains apache
mysql and php which is the things that
we are focusing on as php developers it
also includes a host of other things in
which are you know useful php my admin
is the interface between you and your
mysql database so when you're doing
things like storing uh data in a
database you can need well you don't
need but you it's very useful to use
phpmyadmin
to create tables to insert dummy data
and to review data that's been posted
through your php application
it also includes things like gd which is
the image
manipulation library for php
and a host of other things as well um
what we are focusing on in this tutorial
uh not really tutorial guide
is apache mysql and php
and we'll take a brief look at
phpmyadmin as well
so once you've installed this or
downloaded and installed i'm going to be
using oh i'm showing you on windows but
it's available for linux and mac as well
so let's go ahead and take a look at
what happens once you have installed it
if i head over to here
i'm basically accessing
127.0.0.1 from my browser you can also
use localhost as well
that will bring you to this page and
that note that basically tells you that
you have successfully installed um
apache you can take a look around here i
probably recommend just you know having
a click on a few things and you know
seeing what's going on um it makes sense
to you know take a look at various
things on here since you're going to be
running this in your system
okay so uh the next thing we're going to
look at is the control panel so from
your start menu or or whatever you're
using
you will have this control panel here
and it will tell you what services are
running now you can't see php because
php isn't really a service that runs
it's more part of apache
so apache is our web server and mysql is
our database solution
and you can see that these are both
running at the moment now i've got svc
checked which means that i'm running
these as system processes
so if i go ahead and just bring this
over here
and just expand this a bit you can see
i've got apache 2.2 here and if i type
my uh
my in you can see that we've got mysql
so i start and restart things so restart
or stop
services from here
it might get to the point where you're
developing and you might crash apache or
something like that you know you
you never know um uh you might want to
go ahead and restart it or the same with
mysql as well so you can either do this
from this control panel which i found to
be a bit dodgy it doesn't work as well
as perhaps you'd like it to
so this is why i run a services so i can
just hit restart and that will restart
that particular service
okay so
what we're going to look at next is how
we can go ahead and create our first
page where we go to create our first
page that we can run through our server
and
we're also going to take a brief look at
phpmyadmin as well our database
interface
so let's take a look at the core folder
of xampp and see what it contains
so i'm over in c column backslash x-amp
it'll be different depending on which
operating system that you're running
obviously
but this is the guide for windows we've
got all these
files which are probably somewhat
meaningless to you
most of them are to me but i'm going to
go ahead and take a look at the most
important
php if we need to configure php in any
way you'll find the
php.ini file in here if we scroll down
there it is
and this basically contains some of the
all of the settings that you know relate
to php that we can change
we then can go ahead and restart apache
and this will bring in all these changes
so you'll need to probably change
something in here at some point for
example maximum file upload sizes
certain things that you'll come across
that will give you instruction to go
ahead and edit this file
and this is just a quick note that this
is where you'll find it and remember
head over to wherever you're starting or
restarting apache from restart that
whenever you make a change to your
php.ini file
okay so i have made um
a directory within htdocs and
ah i didn't really explain that very
well at all
so let me go ahead back to x-amp
htdocs is where all of your
files will go that you'll want to show
within your web server or you want to be
accessible within your web server this
can be changed you can go over to apache
conf and
httpd.conf
let's go ahead and edit that
you'll see here that we've got a lotus
you know settings here
and i think if i type root
we've got server route
document route here we go so the
document route is the directory of
which you will serve your documents by
default will request taking this
directory blah blah blah she can go
ahead and change this as well so it
might be c colon backslash or c colon
forward slash web or something like that
um okay so what we're going to do now is
we are going to take a look at
creating a file within these directories
so we've got our config here what we
want to do is we want to head over to
htdocs as i explained earlier and this
will contain a load of files that you
basically a is this that you can see in
the browser at the moment you've got
you'll have an xampp directory as well
so we're actually going to go ahead and
load up our text editor i'm going to go
ahead and i'm just going to type php and
i'm going to end a tag down here this
isn't necessary if you've just got php
in
your
file by the way but you know that's
something to go on later
and i'm going to go ahead and i'm going
to create a file called
index.php
now index.php or
index.something is going to be the file
that by default
uh your web server will hit within a
directory so index.php if you had
index.php and
downloads.php index.php would be hit if
just that directory was accessed so it's
the root file that's accessed basically
so i'm going to go ahead and echo here
test
and we're going to go ahead and try and
run this file so i'm going to go ahead
and open up my browser i'm going to go
localhost forward slash start
and there we go we've got test output
here so we're using we're now using php
so that's where you'd keep all of your
files um
basically we are
you know if you follow the installation
properly you don't have
any applications running that using port
and you can see this local host page and
you can create files within your htdocs
directory
and you get an output like this then you
are ready to go and you can start
writing php